[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Fabrice Almeida pourquoi ne peut-on
jamais parler de l'Afrique sereinement
pour moi c'est c'est un gros problème
d'en parler sereinement parce que ça
rejoint l'histoire intime ça rejoint
l'histoire familiale donc c'est à chaque
fois une
pour ce qui vous concerne exactement et
c'est une tension parce que comme j'ai
eu un mouvement de vie on a vécu là-bas
toute mon enfance est là-bas ensuite je
reviens en freelance voilà mon père
reste là-bas donc il y a une il y a un
mélange de psychologie et de et comment
dirais-je de vie personnelle et par
ailleurs et ensuite toutes les
thématiques politiques des années 60-70
qui ont été celles de mon enfance qui en
permanence me hante dans dans cette
question de qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être
indépendant vous êtes un enfant de
l'indépendance en fait pratiquement
dévoilé de secret vous êtes né en 1963
exact et le Bénin venait d'arriver à
l'indépendance en 60 comme toutes les
colonies à peu près
française il gagne son indépendance
ma mère va se mettre à travailler sur
l'Afrique et
va essayer de tester ces méthodes
éducatives sur nous donc j'ai pas eu une
éducation complètement africaine c'est à
dire que j'avais le droit au coup de
ceinture de papa de temps en temps mais
j'allais droit à maman qui nous disait
jamais un coup ne viendra de moi voilà
d'accord jamais une gifle alors il y en
a un qui a parlé de l'histoire et de
l'Afrique c'est Nicolas Sarkozy quand il
est allé à Dakar juste après son
élection en 2007 il fait une conférence
à l'université Charente à Diop et là il
dit que l'homme africain n'est pas entré
dans l'histoire vous vous êtes historien
vous êtes agrégé l'histoire qu'est-ce
que le regard d'un historien comme vous
peut avoir sur cette ce discours qui est
évidemment beaucoup plus argumenté que
ce que je viens de dire là non mais
c'est un discours qui est à côté de la
plaque en réalité et qui était à côté un
petit peu
on va l'écouter cette visite qui attend
marqué les esprits la voici c'était le
26 juillet 2007 et ce jour-là Nicolas
Sarkozy déclenchait la polémique avec
cette phrase
le drame de l'Afrique c'est que l'homme
africain
n'est pas assez entrée dans l'histoire
n'est pas assez entré dans l'histoire
mais le problème en fait c'est comment
on y rentre et toute la question qui est
posée ici c'est celle de la colonisation
et de l'entrée en contact avec le monde
occidental et cette colonisation c'est
ce que nous avons beaucoup de mal nous
aujourd'hui français à comprendre à
tenir à admettre c'est ce mélange de
brutalité de violence et en même temps
d'une autre partie de la population
ce désir de rencontre d'échanges et de
partage on peut même aller les
Occidentaux des Occidentaux c'est mais
oui mais en même temps il y a la
brutalité et la prise de ces territoires
se fait par la guerre dans le cas du
Bénin on l'a oublié il y a une campagne
militaire qui est menée par un corps
expéditionnaire français qui va arriver
là-bas qui va étant menée par un colonel
au début de la mission qui sera nommé
général pour la guerre qui l'a mené et
qui va détruire le royaume du nom romain
qui était gouverné par béhan ouais qui
fait une guerre assez impitoyable ils
ils sont une supériorité en armement et
donc ils en profitent même si la
première bataille il la perdent avec la
charge phénoménale d'un groupe de femmes
soldats les Amazones les Amazones voilà
qui était l'objet l'objet de
l'admiration et de recherche de ma mère
et qui effectivement votre mère a
travaillé là-dessus on est à la fin du
19e siècle oui oui exactement et c'est
une ça montre cette inégalité dans la
conquête en fait cette inégalité dans la
force et qui fait que l'échange le
commerce la prise des matières premières
Ben se fait sous la contrainte sous la
force quand vous étiez jeune élève dans
ce qui était le Dahomey à l'époque
encore qui s'appelle Dahomey parce que
le Bénin s'est arrivé plus tard est-ce
que vous avez senti cette ce rapport de
force là justement dans les années 60 on
est juste après l'indépendance moi je
suis dans une école africaine l'école
Félicienne adjo qui était une école un
peu expérimentale où on envoyait vous
savez les jeunes instituteurs en
on faisait chaque semaine la levée des
couleurs on chantait l'hymne national ce
qui fait que je l'ai encore dans ma tête
j'ai appris cette hymne là l'hymne dit
d'un Romet avant d'apprendre d'apprendre
l'hymne française La Marseillaise
d'accord et je l'avais je l'avais dans
je l'avais dans la tête et il y avait le
côté comme comme dès qu'il y avait un
blanc c'était le Yovo c'était le blanc
c'était comme ça qu'on l'appelait mais
entre un élève il y avait pas ça en fait
on jouait en fait ce qui est assez
marrant c'est que c'est l'époque les
années 60 où il y a les westerns et donc
tous les gamins dans la cour on est
obsédé par les westerns par les cowboys
les Indiens les shérifs donc on avait ça
puis on avait la conquête de la Lune
faut pas l'oublier parce que il y a 196
événement qui et c'est là où on oublie
on est dans l'histoire les Africains
sont dans l'histoire ils suivent ça ils
sont passionnés par ça
vous avez écrit un livre qui s'appelle
et si on refaitait l'histoire avec
Anthony Rollet qui est un fameux
malheureusement qui nous a quitté mais
un fameux historien est-ce que vous
pouvez pas l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
sur l'Afrique on est en train de refaire
l'histoire et certains veulent la
réécrire justement il y a une nécessité
de la réécrire parce que une bonne
partie de l'histoire a longtemps écrit
été écrite par les vainqueurs parler
dominants donc il y avait la
légitimation des systèmes de domination
et au fond on reprenait l'histoire on la
reprenant par le bas en la reprenant par
le chasseurs comme dit c'est un peu un
proverbe africain juste et donc
heureusement il y a maintenant notamment
grâce à des femmes comme Catherine
Coquerie hydrovitch comme Hélène
danemenato pour ma mère il y a une
génération de chercheurs africains qui
ont pris en charge leur propre sujet je
pense à un Béninois notamment vous avez
m'excuser d'être un peu obsessionnel de
ce territoire mais il y a des
personnages extraordinaires et il y en a
un qui s'appelle Félix Sirocco qui est
un très très grand historien et Sirocco
a commencé à faire des histoires des
pratiques des histoires de
l'environnement il est le premier à
avoir fait une histoire des termitières
en Afrique on pensait pas à ça mais les
termitières sont très très an donc il y
a des strates d'histoire qu'on peut
remarquer à l'intérieur qui permettent
de reconstituer le climat qui permet de
reconstituer des cultures donc voilà il
y a tout un modèle intellectuel qui
émerge et c'est un des historiens qui
justement a repris cette histoire de
l'esclavage et de la traite en Afrique
en la regardant était vraiment en coeur
voilà mais on la regardant oui c'était
l'ancienne côte des esclaves c'était son
nom il y avait la côte de lieu Côte
d'Ivoire et côte des esclaves c'était le
c'était le rivage du Bénin sur le golfe
du Bénin et donc ce territoire là a eu
aussi a fait aussi une partie de sa
fortune et de sa puissance militaire en
vendant des esclaves donc c'est comme ça
qu'aussi on peut reconstituer l'histoire
de de ces États côtiers qui étaient
commerçants mais qui était qui avait une
prospérité grâce à l'esclavage alors
aujourd'hui il y a aussi une tentation
avec la culture la cancelle culture de
réécrire aussi cette histoire et de
gommer justement avec une une vision
morale tout ce qui a pu se passer par
le passé qui ne passe pas finalement je
suis pas sûr que en Afrique ce soit là
comme ça le couture au contraire en
Afrique c'est plutôt la conteste culture
c'est à dire que on conteste un certain
état des choses une certaine vision du
monde qui suppose que les l'ordre
démocratique soit le même partout qui
suppose que les modèles d'échange soit
les mêmes partout et ce qu'on appelle le
panafricanisme qui a changé un peu de
visage d'ailleurs notamment mais qui
essaye au fond c'est l'idée de réfléchir
à la domination et à la domination et au
rôle de dominant que certaines élites
africaines ont eu donc d'où tiennent
tenait-elle dans légitimité il y a une
génération qui est arrivée qui est
arrivée parce que elle est arrivée dans
la lutte on a oublié un mais les fouets
de poignées etc ils deviennent ministres
mais ils deviennent ministres en partant
d'une position au départ opposée
adversaire concurrente d'administrent en
sa quatrième exactement en France
exactement
alors qu'il portait alors qu'il portait
un discours d'autonomie puis un discours
d'indépendance donc c'est c'est des
choses c'est c'est des mouvements qui
étaient très forts et eux ils ont cette
légitimité d'avoir gagné d'une certaine
manière l'indépendance mais les
générations qui viennent après tout
est-elle leur légitimité de la Force du
vote de la filiation donc tout ça pose
beaucoup de
problèmes et en explique cette culture
de la contestation pour les gouvernants
et pour ceux qui éventuellement jouent
les marionnettistes derrière et est-ce
qu'il y a pas justement une une espèce
de conflit générationnel entre ceux qui
d'une certaine façon de participer à ces
indépendances on luttés pour
l'indépendance mais finalement ce sont
accommodés d'une certaine façon du passé
colonial et puis aujourd'hui justement
cette jeunesse africaine qui est
beaucoup plus virulente et qui veut
justement et bien couper les ponts d'une
certaine façon avec la culture
occidentale c'est ambivalent parce que
le
nerf si on se promène dans les rues de
Lagos ou même si on se promène dans les
rues de de ville d'État développer comme
l'Afrique du Sud
on a tous le rêve américain on a tous le
rêve de
la vie belle facile etc c'est un rêve
que l'enfant l'enfant occidental partage
avec l'enfant africain qui a ce mythe il
y a cette idée aussi qu'on va pouvoir
aller dans ces pays-là pour
éventuellement tenter sa chance et faire
fortune donc là-dessus il y a toujours
une très très grande attractivité en
revanche là où il y a une contestation
c'est l'idée de dire qu'il y a qu'un
modèle unique qui leur serait imposé de
ça et c'est le reproche qu'on fait
souvent
c'est une reproche qu'on fait souvent en
français c'est de donner l'impression
de discours de Nicolas Sarkozy en a un
petit peu le lundi de donner
l'impression qu'il y a qu'une manière de
se développer qui a qu'une manière
d'être qui soit positive au monde et
c'est ça qui souvent sait que il cherche
des alternatives d'autres d'autres
groupes pour les aider jadis c'était
l'URSS aujourd'hui c'est la Chine et la
Russie parce que ils cherchent
l'alternat pour avoir leur propre
logique de développement leur propre
logique de définition de la légitimité
et de la culture même il y a une volonté
de réappropriation justement de son
identité on le voit d'ailleurs avec
aujourd'hui la restitution des œuvres
d'art aussi de son identité de sa
culture et d'ailleurs le Bénin est au
premier chef concerné puisque ça fait
pas mal de bruit il y a eu la
restitution des statues qui sont là qui
paraissent petites mais qui sont
beaucoup plus grandes que ça des stages
le royaume d'Abomey
statues des trois rois qui se sont
succédés
qui ont construit un véritable royaume
une puissance militaire et qui sont
vaincus et ces statues sont prises dans
le palais royal d'abonnés par le général
Dodge qui les rapporte en France comme
trophée de la victoire militaire et
c'est vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron a pris la
décision de de les rendre de les
restituer après le rapport fait par deux
personnalité dominante ça et sa voix et
au fond ça me pose une question parce
que le Bénin actuel il a été en partie
construit par ceux qui étaient pour la
défaite du royaume d'abomé parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'elle est Pâques le
royaume de Ouidah et Porto-Novo sont
plutôt sous l'influence française et
donc sont opposés au royaume d'abomec
qui essaye de leur de leur imposer ça
règle par la force et en fait
aujourd'hui et notamment Porto-Novo
était était était était concurrent de ce
royaume donc ça c'est assez amusant de
se dire que on restitue ça un état qui
prend comme
identité l'État qui s'est battu et qui
minorisent qui qui donne une position
mineure en fait à ceux qui étaient
j'allais dire les collabos et pour le
coup j'en parle comme ça parce que c'est
ma famille alors qu'au fond moi
j'appartiens à un groupe qui est très
connu des Africains qui est-ce qu'on
appelle les afro brésiliens faire des
gens qui sont des descendants soit
d'esclaves soit de personnes qui sont
partis en traite comme on dit en au
Brésil qui sont là-bas devenu libre et
qui sont revenus en portant les noms de
leurs anciens maîtres d'Almeida c'est
mon nom c'est un nom qui vient du Brésil
c'est un nom portugais
ma nationalité quand ma famille revient
en Afrique elle est portugaise parce
qu'on revient avant l'indépendance du
Brésil on revient on est portugais on
s'inscrit à Porto-Novo dans le fort
portugais et on est pour les Français
pourquoi parce qu'on est fait du
commerce on a une maison de commerce et
on veut que les Français viennent parce
qu'avec eux il y aura la tranquillité la
sécurité on pourra continuer le business
et c'est ce qui fait qu'une partie de ma
famille va être secrétaire général du
gouverneur et que mon oncle Ignace au
Pinto va être dans le même parti que
vous faites Boigny sénateur de la
République sur la quatrième et aussi ce
qui explique que la religion du vaudou
et bien est partagée aussi bien en
Amérique latine et notamment au Brésil
et au Bénin puisque c'est vraiment le
pays d'Afrique où on cultive cette culte
du vaudou et qui aujourd'hui encore
démultiplié par rapport à ce qu'il était
par le passé parce que c'est aussi un
une attraction touristique tu peux le
dire aujourd'hui ouais bon après il y a
ceux qui croient ouais c'est vrai que
quand on a quand on a vécu quelques
années là-bas on finit par avoir une
trouille bleue de parler de ce genre de
choses parce que il y a toujours la
menace du sorcier il y a toujours la
menace de la de la de la du sort qui va
être jeté à distance mais au fond quand
on était en vacances dans les années 60
on allait en Bourgogne dans le Morvan et
donne Morvan il y avait encore un petit
peu cet esprit superstitieux campagne
française ont gardé et on faisait très
attention quand quelqu'un vous faisait
des cornes c'était pas si loin Fabrice
d'Almeida quand vous regardez le
continent africain et qu'on regarde un
peu la politique telle qu'elle se
déroule aujourd'hui ce qui a pas un
recul quand même d'une démocratie qui
commençait à s'installer dans les années
dans les années 90 les années 2000 et
aujourd'hui on le voit à travers des
coups d'État au Sahel notamment au Mali
au Burkina Faso mais un recul de
démocratie moi j'y vois justement la
preuve que l'Afrique est dans l'histoire
et elle est vraiment dans l'histoire
parce que ce qui se passe en Afrique en
réalité est tout à fait parallèle à ce
qu'on voit en Amérique latine avec la
montée en puissance d'un bolsonaro
espèce de populisme avec ce qui a pu se
passer au Venezuela aussi avec Chaves et
son successeur Maduro on voit la même
chose aux États-Unis avec Trump ou la
question de la pratique démocratique et
remise en cause et on le voit aussi en
France ou il y a le même débat sur
escortation populiste et oui et est-ce
que nos institutions sont encore bonnes
est-ce qu'il faut les changer et donc
les Africains sont traversés par les
mêmes coûts les mêmes les mêmes
situations et d'autant plus j'allais
dire que ils ont une vigueur économique
qui n'ont pas eu pendant longtemps
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait taux de
croissance depuis les années qui sont
extrêmement importants il y a de la
richesse il y a des il y a des figures
qui émergent enfin faut penser à ce
continent dans les années 60 n'avait pas
de vrais riches les riches pour
l'essentiel étaient des occidentaux
depuis les années 2000 on a et même ça
commence dans on a des très grandes
fortunes africaines on a des gens qui
sont des milliardaires à ALIKO Dangote
par exemple au Nigeria c'est une figure
qui représente la même chose que ce que
peut représenter un Bernard Arnault en
France donc c'est la capacité que ces
données se continent d'organiser
lui-même son investissement et ça c'est
absolument crucial et donc on remarque
au fond la même chose la même évolution
de la même logique d'évolution que en
Europe aux États-Unis et d'ailleurs il
est l'objet de toutes les convoitises
aujourd'hui ce continent et britanniques
et surtout les Français qui sont un peu
nostalgiques de la grandeur d'antan
quand ils étaient très influents sur ce
continent mais aujourd'hui il y a les
Chinois il y a les Russes il y a les
Turcs il y a les Israéliens il y a les
Iraniens c'est libanais ce qui remplace
les Libanais c'est le c'est le continent
du 21e siècle mais c'est le continent en
fait où il y a besoin le plus
d'équipements donc à la fois c'est un
marché et par ailleurs c'est le
continent qui a énormément de ressources
naturelles qui semblent aux autres plus
accessibles plus facile et moins cher
donc c'est pour ça qu'il se joue
aujourd'hui et je pense dans les
décennies qui vont qui vont venir une
lutte très très virulente pour à la fois
tenir le marché et tenir les matières
premières et c'est tout le c'est tout
l'enjeu mais j'allais dire c'est un peu
le drame de l'Afrique ce continent est
toujours regardé comme une ressource et
je pense que ce qui est en train de
changer c'est que la montée en puissance
économique en en faisant un marché va
obliger aussi une partie des acteurs
économiques à modifier leur attitude
alors il y a un grand intellectuel qui
enseigne aux États-Unis qui est
sénégalais qui s'appelle Souleyman
Bachir Ndiaye et qui dit il est grand
temps il est urgent que maintenant on
regarde le monde depuis l'Afrique ça
veut dire quoi ça bah ça veut dire que à
chaque fois il y a eu des polarités dans
l'histoire du monde et que le regard du
le regard universel à tout était en fait
à partir d'un centre parce que c'est
aussi un pape de l'universel Souleyman
bachirer
mais c'est vrai que le regard posé à
partir de là et c'est d'ailleurs très
frappant quand on frappe quand on fait
quand on des cartes on se rend compte
que on peut modifier la centralité vous
souvenez les cartes qu'on nous avait
nous quand on était petit elles étaient
toutes centrées sur la France donc on
avait l'impression que le monde entier
était organisé à partir de nous les
voies maritimes feraient etc et bien à
partir de l'Afrique effectivement on
constate qu'il y a d'incroyables routes
et je te mains de commerce et
d'industrie qui se qui sont qui sont
mises en place donc effectivement je
crois que décentré ce regard là est
absolument cruciale et de pas seulement
passer d'un regard qui sera au départ
américain pour ensuite en faire un
regard chinois alors sauf qu'aujourd'hui
les routes dont vous parlez Fabrice
dalmeda c'est elle se ressemble aussi à
des routes de la tragédie du tragique
avec cette exil avec ces routes de
migration finalement où on voit ceux qui
partent d'Afrique qui fuient la misère
le réchauffement climatique
la dictature et bien souvent c'est ceux
qui peuvent se le permettre c'est à dire
ceux qui sont éduqués qui sont riches
enfin qui sont riches sur les moyens de
le faire c'est le drame de l'Afrique ça
non qu'elle se vide oui et c'est un
drame ancien parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on continue aujourd'hui sous une
autre forme la la ponction démographique
qu'on avait effectué sur ce continent
pratiquement depuis le Moyen-âge parce
que il y a eu la traite musulmane
ensuite la traite occidentale et en fait
à chaque fois le dynamisme démographique
a été a été pris mais je crois que là on
est on est dans autre chose parce que ce
que ça pose comme question pour moi
c'est à la fois la question que ça pose
chez nous en France et en Europe plus
largement et celle de l'homogénéité
culturelle et tout le débat qu'on a et
qui est la serrant dans notre société
depuis les années 80 avec la montée du
Front national puis du rassemblement
national mais ça pose la même question
en Afrique c'est-à-dire l'intolérance
qu'on a par rapport à certains groupes
ethniques et ce qui me frappe c'est que
nous on regarde souvent les États
africains comme des États qui sont
donnés avec le la même logique
d'homogénéité que la nôtre mais en
réalité à l'intérieur
il y a une nécessité qui est extrêmement
puissante extrêmement vigoureuse et qui
explique parfois des tensions internes
très très violentes et donc des
poursuites des rejets et des nécessités
de fuite et ce qui me frappe c'est pour
ça que c'est important cette culture
universelle c'est d'essayer justement de
d'avoir cette universalisme de
l'humanité pour pouvoir cohabiter et pas
seulement j'allais dire cette
cette exigence obsessionnelle ou de la
nationalité ou de l'électricité qui
finit par construire du conflit du
massacre et de la liquidation alors vous
vous êtes particulièrement exposés à ça
parce que vous êtes métisse
c'est dur de parfois alors en Afrique on
va vous dire que vous n'êtes pas
africain et peut-être je me permets en
France on vous dit que vous n'êtes pas
français moi j'ai une chance j'ai une
chance inouïe je veux dire enfin
je vis dans un pays qui m'a accepté mais
qui m'a accepté et qui m'a donné des
choses
qui sont inimaginables
ce pays m'a éduqué
ce pays
à en partie protéger ma mère qui était
d'origine juive et qui aurait pu mourir
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
qui a été enfin caché donc ce pays a été
pour moi pour nous une chance et il me
permet aujourd'hui même de
devenir témoigner dans une dans une
émission de télévision sur une chaîne
parlementaire donc sur une chaîne qui
appartient j'allais dire aux
institutions publiques françaises donc
c'est c'est ça que je vois moi je j'ai
un rapport à la France qui est
extrêmement
comment dirais-je
j'ai une dette envers la France pour le
dire autrement c'est à dire que je lui
dois beaucoup je lui dois beaucoup et
votre rapport à l'Afrique
l'Afrique c'est le continent qui était
sud de mon père c'est un continent où je
vais de temps en temps mais
je vais le dire autrement en fait
l'Afrique ça a été le début de mon
engagement militant la première
engagement militante que j'ai fait
c'était au lycée Turgot et on a créé
avec Léa 10 Soglo qui était le neveu qui
a été Président
le fils pardonica mais le neveu du
général Soglo qui avait été déjà chef
d'État dans les années 60 et les a dit
et un certain nombre James cammartin on
a créé un comité affront antillais et
précisément parce que dans ce pays la
France qui nous donnait beaucoup on
avait le sentiment que il y avait une
toute petite reconnaissance qui serait
nécessaire
de de ce que nous étions et on était
très énervé du fait que tout le monde
pensait pouvoir parler d'Afrique sans
jamais demander à des gens qui étaient
d'origine africaine je crois que ça a
bien changé n'est-ce pas il serait bah
oui oui la preuve
et donc cet engagement militant c'est ça
et au fond l'Afrique pour moi c'est ça
c'est le
le moteur d'une solidarité est-ce que
vous qui êtes historien qui enseignait
encore à l'université mais est-ce que
puisque les rapports sont aussi étroits
entre la frite francophone l'Afrique de
l'Ouest et du Nord et la France est-ce
qu'on enseigne suffisamment justement
cette histoire là à l'école je dirais à
l'école je suis pas sûr en tout cas ce
qui me frappe c'est que nous à
l'université maintenir les liens et
compliqués parce que plus on prend des
mesures restrictives sur les visas plus
on prend des mesures restrictives sur
l'immigration plus ça rend compliqué le
parcours de nos étudiants donc ça ça a
été un moment et je me souviens
notamment d'une autre historienne Claude
Hélène Perrault qui était intervenu
auprès du président Chirac pour qu'on
puisse avoir des visas étudiants
beaucoup plus légers beaucoup plus
facile alors que même montait déjà tout
ce discours contre les échanges
académiques comme
durant une forme cachée de d'immigration
donc moi je suis très attentif à ça à
l'école en fait ce qu'on apprend malgré
tout c'est un peu la géographie et je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on apprenne plus
parce que justement le monde voit ses
échanges certes reculer un petit peu en
volume le commerce mondial est un peu
plus faible que dans les années 2000
mais la mondialisation reste quand même
un processus très très important et donc
connaître les autres continents mieux
connaître les autres cultures je pense
que c'est un bénéfice pour les élèves de
France et d'une certaine façon la
mondialisation était une chance pour
l'Afrique non
il y a eu deux mondialisations
lesquelles il y a la première
mondialisation qui est celle qui va du
16e siècle jusqu'à la fin du du 19e
siècle et la mondialisation coloniale là
elle a été voilà et il y a la deuxième
mondialisation qui commence à partir des
années 80 comme les organisations
elle donne l'opportunité aux Africains
d'entreprendre leur propre développement
et d'essayer de de créer une richesse
c'est important la richesse c'est pas la
théorie du ruissellement mais s'il y a
pas de riche il y a pas d'investissement
pourquoi parce que sinon c'est l'État
qui s'en occupe et l'État en général ne
voit pas très bien où sont les besoins
Fabrice d'Almeida s'il y avait une
figure
culturels ou politiques ou économiques
qui pour vous symbolise le continent
africain ça serait laquelle mais moi
j'ai envie d'en prendre un qui symbolise
une certaine forme de fierté africaine
quand on a vu la statue tout à l'heure
j'ai envie de prendre le roi des eaux le
roi parce que c'est un fondateur c'est
quelqu'un qui met en place des
institutions qui modernise son pays qui
ouvrent on est en cas de période on est
au début du 19e siècle et qui ouvre son
son état qu'il est en train de
constituer au commerce avec le monde
occidental et qui va avoir un état
florissant ce qui lui permet de se
développer ce qui va lui permettre
pendant un temps
de faire vivre ce pays jusqu'à son
petit-fils Béhanzin qui lui n'arrivera
pas à résister à la conquête française
malgré malgré un barreau de d'honneur et
qui finira exiler et exilé outre-mer
donc voilà j'aime bien cette dynastie je
trouve que elle explique quelque chose
de l'histoire de ce continent le Bénin
dont on disait à un moment qu'il était
le quartier latin de l'Afrique et mes
parents se sont connus au Quartier Latin
et j'aime à m'en souvenir merci Fabrice
d'Almeida merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]